time now for morning rounds with CBS
News chief medical correspondent dr. Jon
LaPook and CBS News contributor dr. Tara
Narula first up a serious condition that
could be triggered by eating gluten
celiac disease is an autoimmune disorder
that impacts both adults and children
it's estimated that a little less than
1% of American adults have celiac
disease but most cases go undetected
this week the US Preventive Services
Task Force issued their recommendation
on the effectiveness of the screening
process as published in the Journal of
the American Medical Association
so dr. LaPook what did the task force
conclude I'm a gastroenterologist I deal
with this issue all the time and here's
the context of it on the one hand you
have this condition celiac disease that
affects a lot of people and it can be
very tough to diagnose you can have
obvious symptoms but it can be very
subtle on the other hand you've got a
lot of people out there who are on these
gluten-free diets who really don't have
celiac so should you be testing people
who don't have any obvious symptoms that
was the big question we've been waiting
for this for years and drum roll they
said who knows we do not have enough
data and it's something that has to be
decided between the patient and the
doctor so that's why we're gonna talk
about it today you get a little bit more
detail Tara why is it so hard to
diagnose so it can be tricky just like
John said because it can master it as a
lot of different things you can have
patients who have no symptoms patient
have mild symptoms to severe symptoms to
atypical symptoms so the more common
things would be abdominal pain bloating
diarrhea but you can also have symptoms
like fatigue or neurologic symptoms or
an Emir osteoporosis so the problem is
that it can take many years to diagnose
people appropriately and during that
time there can be damage happening to
the small intestine so John okay you
mentioned this is your field of studies
and what's the opinion of you and your
colleagues on diagnosing and testing I
think the bottom line here is that
everybody doctors to have to have a much
better level of suspicion about it there
are often pediatricians who notice that
some kid may have a little bit of low
iron or anemia and not really be
aggressive you should test that person
for celiac because to see if maybe
they're not absorbing their nutrients
correctly there are conditions like
brain fog
and learning disabilities that have been
associated with celiac disease and so if
you have that maybe that's somebody who
should be tested why shouldn't everybody
just go ahead and do a seal gluten-free
diet well it's a pain in the neck to do
a gluten isn't everything it's in soy
sauce it's in a ton of things if you
have french fries that might not have
gluten but it was fried up in something
where previously it was cross
contaminated with gluten because it was
fried chicken then you have to worry so
there's your serological testing their
blood tests we need to do a lot better a
lot more research to figure out who
should be tested and when bottom line
here high level of suspicion doesn't
have to be big-time symptoms of diarrhea
and abdominal pain could be no symptoms
or subtle symptoms are there
complications that can arise from a
celiac disease there can be and so the
evidence shows that it is associated
with an increased mortality and there
are complications from malabsorption of
certain nutrients so you can develop
anemia or bone fracture some
osteoporosis it's also been associated
with some neurological changes as John
mentioned also reproductive and
obstetric problems and then in rare
cases it's associated with lymphoma and
other types of intestinal cancers
migraines osteoporosis shortstack
everything other things a big list all
right our next topic watching your sugar
intake it is important for anyone's diet
but can it can be even more
consequential for those with health
problems like metabolic syndrome a group
of health issues like how high blood
sugar and obesity that in turn can
increase your chances of developing
certain chronic illnesses like diabetes
and cardiovascular disease a recent
study published in the european journal
of nutrition referred to estimates
showing nearly 35 percent of all
american adults and half of those 60 and
older suffered from metabolic syndrome
in 2011 and 2012 the study looked at a
small group of patients who received
some dietary counseling while following
the american heart association's 2006
dietary guidelines and examined if this
diet was effective in decreasing added
sugar tara what did this study show us
right so I think it really speaks to the
power of nutritional support and dietary
counseling and I tell a lot of my
patients they should work with the
nutritionist I think that's why programs
like Weight Watchers or Jenny Craig can
be successful because it gives people
that added support so in this study
there were 119 people who were given
information about
AAA's diet but also received individual
and group counseling sessions over the
course of a year at the end of that year
they were able to decrease their added
sugar by about 24 grams which sounds
great and it is great but the problem is
that about 48 percent were still over
the recommended amount which for men is
about 9 teaspoons a day or 36 grams of
added sugar and for women about 6
teaspoons a day or 24 grams of added
sugar
they sneak sugar into every finally time
for some practical advice this week the
importance of knowing your family's
medical history John and Tara how just
how far back do we need to go here yeah
I think this is so important people
don't give it a lot of the credit that
it deserves so many times I ask my
patients you know tell me about your
mother and father or your brother and
sister and they have no idea but
especially in cardiovascular disease it
plays a big role in determining your
risk for things like coronary artery
disease heart failure electrical
abnormalities and it really helps us
guide how we diagnose people what tests
we might order and how we treat them
preventively yeah and it's not you know
people think about heart disease and
cancer but it's other things it's Galit
it's kidney stones it's mental illness
there are all sorts of things that you
can get clues at and of course one of
the problems is that back then people
didn't they weren't that open about
their problems so often somebody will
come to me and they say well I don't
really know I think she had stomach
cancer
well stomach cancer could be colon
cancer which would mean they have to get
screened maybe earlier so try to get as
many details as you can ask questions
don't take no for an answer all right
doctors Jon LaPook and Tara Narula
thanks